Bitte schön.
Hallo, wie ist es mit meinem Namen?
Ich bin einer der zuständigen Erste für Sie und würde gerne mit dieser Gespräche führen.
Wenn Sie Fragen haben, sagen Sie mir einen Bescheid. Dann machen wir ein kurzer Pause.
Okay, alles klar.
Erst mal können Sie mir Ihren Namen verraten bitte.
Ich bin gerne, mein Name ist Klaus Biber.
Können Sie Ihren Namen?
B-I-B-E-R.
Herr Biber, ne?
Genau.
Herr Biber, wie alt sind Sie bitte?
Ich bin 50 Jahre alt.
50.
Und wann sind Sie gerne geboren?
Am 24. Januar 1973.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin ungefähr ein Meter 71 groß.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Zirke 88 Kilogramm.
Alles klar.
Herr Biber, was fühlt Sie zu uns denn?
Ich komme heute Sonntag zu Ihnen in die Aufnahme, weil ich seit 18 Jahren in der Stadt bin.
Ich bin jetzt auf der Straße.
Ich komme heute Sonntag zu Ihnen in die Aufnahme, weil ich seit drei Tagen Schmerzen im Unterbauch habe.
Und die immer schlimmer werden.
Unterbauch.
Wofür lösen Sie die Schmerzen genau?
Im Unterbauch links?
Ja, aber auch ein bisschen rechts.
Das kommt immer noch an.
Strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwo hin?
Nein, nur im Unterbauch.
Und nur linke Seite?
Hauptsächlich links.
Können Sie die Schmerzen beschreiben?
Ist das sehr drückend?
Krampfartig vielleicht?
Drückend.
Auch stechend.
Kann ich nicht ganz gut beschreiben.
Ist das sehr dumpf für Schmerz?
Oder stechend?
Ja, also auch krampfartig eigentlich.
Ein bisschen gemischt.
Sind die Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten oder eher allmählich?
Nee, allmählich.
Da seid drei Tage jetzt zunehmend.
Sind die Schmerzen immer da oder treten Sie nur hin und wieder auf?
Also manchmal werden sie weniger.
Und dann wird sie aber auch wieder mehr.
Wenn Sie eher Schmerzen messen, würden Sie auf eine Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10.
Wobei 1 für am leichtsten und 10 für am stärksten Schmerzen nicht.
Wo würden Sie eher Schmerzen einstufen?
Also wenn Sie tatsächlich kommen, dann sind Sie manchmal sogar auf 7.
7.
Es muss schwer gewesen sein für Sie.
Brauchen Sie einen Schmerz mit?
Ja, ich verstehe.
Können Sie die Schmerzen bis Ende unseres Gesprächs aushalten oder brauchen Sie einen Schmerz mit?
Nee, ich habe eben noch Ibuprofen genommen.
Wie viel Milligramm haben Sie sich angenommen?
Ich hatte zu Hause noch die 400 Tage.
Da habe ich jetzt seit zwei Tagen nicht da regelmäßig welche ein.
Wie viel Mal haben Sie?
Ich habe mich nicht gezählt.
Bestimmt 4, 5, vielleicht noch 6 Mal, weiß ich nicht.
Also es war gestern.
Hat es Ihnen geholfen?
Ja, ein bisschen.
Es lindert den Schmerz.
Haben Sie auch etwas bemerkt, dass die Schmerzen lindert oder verschlechtert?
Also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, wenn ich auf Toilette bin, nach der Toilette geht es mir besser.
Haben Sie etwas Ungewöhnliches gegessen in den letzten drei Tagen?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Haben Sie Stuhlprobleme?
Eigentlich nicht, aber jetzt in den letzten Tagen schon so ein bisschen.
Das ist immer unrechtlich.
Einiges ja Durchfall oder Verstockfunk.
Eigentlich nicht, aber jetzt in den letzten Tagen variiert das ein bisschen.
Mal so, mal so.
Mal Durchfall, mal...
Genau.
Und wie viel Mal mussten Sie auch die Toilette gehen, zum Beispiel, wenn Sie Durchfall haben?
Ja, sich ungefähr so 3, 4 Mal am Tag.
Seit gestern jetzt.
Und haben Sie Blutspuren im Stuhl bemerkt?
Hab ich nicht bemerkt.
Alles klar.
Hatten Sie Fieber vielleicht?
Oder fühlen Sie sich fieberig?
Nicht wirklich, nein.
Oder ist Ihnen Herzrasen, Herzklopfen aufgefallen?
Haben Sie noch weitere Beschwerden wie Kopfschmerzen, Brustschmerzen, Brusten?
Nein.
Sind diese Beschwerden erst mal nicht aufgetreten?
Ja, ich habe sie noch nicht.
Ich bin ein bisschen gesorgt.
Beim anderen Arzt?
Nein, war ich auch nicht.
Ja, ganz verständlich.
Aber Sie haben sich sehr gut entschieden, indem Sie hierher gekommen sind.
Also haben Sie keine...
Meinen Sie, das könnte Darmkrebs sein?
Nein, eine Darmkrebs sehe ich unwahrscheinlich.
Aber auf jeden Fall werden wir sowohl mit operativ diagnostik Verfahren,
als auch mit körperlich Untersuchung ein Krebs ausschließen.
Keine Sorge.
Der Vater meines Freundes, der ist an Darmkrebs verstorben.
Nein, meine Beinleit.
Ich möchte auch gerne wissen, ob bei Ihnen etwas...
gibt es Ihnen hier vor, die Geschichte wichtige Krankheiten vorliegt?
Zum Beispiel leiden Sie an Bluthochdruck,
höchter Blutwettwerte, der sonstig ist?
Ich habe einen Bluthochdruck.
Seit wann?
Der ist schon seit fast fünf Jahren jetzt vorhanden.
Und ich nehme dafür Ramipril ein einmal morgens.
Ramipril, wie viel Millimeter haben Sie?
5 Millirern.
Und weitere Krankheiten?
Und ich habe eine höhte Haaransorgungspiegel.
Und da nehme ich alloproinol für einen.
Alloproinol, wie viel?
100 Millirern.
Einmal, ne?
Ja, morgens einmal.
Momentan ist Ihnen ein Schluckstörungen aufgefallen?
Schluckstörungen?
Nein.
Schmerzhafte Schlucken oder vielleicht soeures Aufstoßen?
Ist Ihnen vielleicht Therstuhl aufgefallen?
Was bedeutet Therstuhl?
Therstuhl, ich meine schwarze Stuhl, wenn Sie Stuhl ranken.
Nein, ich bin nicht aufgefallen.
Oder hatten Sie vielleicht Stuhl verhalten?
Nein, aber ich habe gemerkt, dass ich halt jetzt so wechselnden Stuhl habe.
Einmal ein bisschen Durchfall, dann kommt wieder Therstuhl.
Und dann kann man wieder durchfallen, bis in den letzten Tagen.
Nur seit zwei Tagen oder auch schon lange?
Nein, seit zwei Tagen jetzt.
Alles klar.
Und Sie, okay.
Haben Sie schon mal operiert?
Nein, ganz lange nicht.
Gibt es auch andere Medikamente, die Sie gelegentlich oder bei Bedanken...
Ja, Ibuprofen halten zum Beispiel.
Wenn ich Schmerzen habe, wenn ich Schmerzen habe,
wenn ich Bauchschmerzen habe, nehme ich das schon mal ein.
Ist bei Ihnen allergien- oder verträglichkeiten bekannt?
Nein.
Herr Biber, rauchen Sie?
Ich rauche ja.
Seit wann und wie viel?
Also ich habe mal zwischenzeitig aufgehört, aber jetzt rauche ich wieder seit ungefähr 10 Jahren wieder.
Und ungefähr eine halbe Schachtrauch.
Wenn Sie mit dem Rauchen aufhören möchten,
ich kann für Sie einen Termin bei unseren Sozialdienstvereinbaren.
Wir haben auch ein Ölungsprogramm,
die ich gerne...
Gerne.
Ja, auch trinken Sie auch Alkohol?
Sehr, sehr selten.
Vielleicht ein paar Mal im Jahr.
Ist klar.
Ich vertrage kein Alkohol.
Das ist eine routine Frage, Herr Biber.
Haben Sie Erfahrungen mit Drohlen?
Ja, in meiner Jugend habe ich immer etwas geraucht, aber aktuell nicht.
Nein.
Aber das haben Sie ausprobiert, vielleicht?
Kann aber nicht.
Und wir sind fast fertig, aber jetzt auch möchte ich ein paar Fragen über Ihr Familie und unser Sozialleben stellen.
Alles in Ordnung?
Bei mir ist alles in Ordnung, ja.
Ich habe nur Schmerz nachgedacht.
Ja, werden wir sofort darum kümmern.
Sind die Eltern noch am Leben?
Meine Eltern leben beide noch, ja.
Danke.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Krankheiten?
Mein Vater hat etwas am Herzen.
Er hat auch Blutdruck, er hat auch einen Stemp bekommen.
Meine Mutter hat Schildgrüßung unter Funktionen.
Und eine beginnende Zucker.
Also Diabetes, wurde mir gesagt.
Ja.
Haben Sie auch Geschwister?
Ich habe eine Schwester, die ist gesund.
Und was brauchen Sie, wer liegt da?
Ich bin selbstständig.
Ich habe eine kleine Firma, wo wir Möbel bauen und verkaufen.
Haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit?
Ich mache immer.
Selbstständig habe ich immer Stress.
Sind Sie frei?
Ich bin ledig.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Freiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Es könnte mehr sein.
Ich gehe viel Fahrer, wenn das Wetter gut ist.
Ansonsten spazieren mit dem Hund.
Waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Ich habe vor drei Monaten in Deutschland.
Oder haben Sie eine lange Reise gemacht?
Nein, ich war vor drei Monaten in Holland.
Im Truppen oder irgendwo anders?
Nein, keine Zeit gehabt.
Ich gucke, ob ich noch weitere Informationen brauche.
Würden Sie noch etwas hinzufügen über Ihre Ebene?
Ich bin besorgt.
Ich möchte wissen, ob ich hier bleibe muss.
Ob das etwas gefährlicher sein könnte.
Deswegen bin ich heute hier.
Das werde ich morgen zu meinem Hausarzt gegangen.
Ich möchte es heute abgeklärt haben.
Ich gehe davon aus.
Es wäre besser,
wenn Sie hier bleiben, bis alle unsere Muttersungen abgeschlossen sind.
Je nach Ergebnis können wir weiter sprechen.
Aber ich empfehle, hier ein bisschen zu bleiben.
Ich bin selbstständig.
Ich muss mal zur Firma zurück.
Ich verstehe, dass Ihre Arbeit oder Ihr Leben wichtig ist.
Aber Ihre Gesundheit ist wichtig.
Ich bin selbstständig.
Ich weiß, dass Ihr Leben wichtig.
Aber Ihre Gesundheit ist wesentlich wichtiger.
Sie sollen hierbleiben.
Es kann ein Problem mit dem Darm sein.
Wie müssen wir feststellen, was das ist?
Okay.
Bisııinuss.
Vielen Dank.
Dann krebs? Nein, der Vater meines Freundes. Deswegen habe ich ein bisschen Angst und bin heute hier.
Ich möchte das abgeklärt haben. Haben Sie Übelkeit, brüchen Sie?
Also wenn ich Schmerzen habe, habe ich auch ein bisschen Übelkeit, aber erbrochen habe ich noch nicht bisher.
Als das geschieht, können wir anfangen?
Noch ein kleiner Minuteschermit.
Wenn ich Schmerzen verlinse, das heißt, umdelenen, ist normal?
Kann man sagen, ja? Wir können anfangen.
Guten Tag Herr Oberrass. Ich habe einen neuen Patient aufgenommen. Hatten Sie kurz Zeit für mich? Ich würde gerne vorstellen.
Gerne, danke.
Herr Beber-Klaus, 50-jähriger Patient. Unser Patient ist 1 Meter, 71, groß und 88 kg schwer.
Er kam zu uns mit seit 3 Tagen bestehende Unterbauchschmerzen links.
Er beschreibt die Schmerzen als drückend, stechend und krampfartig.
Die Schmerzen seien langsam aufgetreten und liegen bei 7 von 10 auf eine Schmerzkala.
Bei einem Namen von 4 bis 5 Maligern, 400 mg, habe ich ihm ein bisschen Blinderung gebracht.
Die Schmerzen würden sich beim Toilettengang verbessern.
Nach dem Toilettengang.
Er erwähnt über die Durchfall- und Konstipation im Wechsel.
Er hat durch die Durchfall bis 4 Tage bis 3 Tage, 4 Mal am Tag und genau sehr.
Die Frage nach Feber, Hermesis, Inapetens, Tachycardi, Disfagi, so etwas aufstoßen, wurden vereint.
Er hat eine kranken Geschichte.
Er hat eine Artealipatone seit 5 Jahren.
Er ist bekannt.
Er hat 5 mg Ramipril, 1 Mal morgens und 100 mg.
Er ist manchmal pro Fenbrei bedarf.
Er ist nicht allergie- und unverdurchschnittlich.
Er ist traucher, seit 10 Jahren, halbschaftlich.
Er hat 5 Paket.
Er ist ein seltener Alkoholkonsum, 1-2 Mal im Jahr.
Er ist ein Cannabiskonsum als Jugend.
Er ist komplett im Status.
Er zeigt sich Artealipatone und Corners Herzkrankheit beim Vater.
Er wurde mit Stand behandelt.
Er ist hypotriose und diabetes-Meilitus bei der Mutter.
Er ist eine gesunde Schwester.
Er ist selbstständiger.
Er hat seine eigene Möbelfima.
Er hat Stress bei der Arbeit.
Er ist ledig.
Er hat keine Kinder.
Er ist unverfällig.
Er ist ein Infektions-Pastroenteritis.
Er ist auch Reisdarm-Syndrom.
Er hat Konich-Ernzündig-Darm-Erkrankungen.
Um zu bestätigen,
würde ich zuerst die Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Vor allem Baupalpation.
Und vielleicht Digital-Rectal-Untersuchung.
Und würde ich Blut abnehmen und ins Labor schicken.
Im Labor achte ich auf Entzündungswerte wie Zera-Aktivs, Protein,
Blut-Senkung, Geschwindigkeit, auch die Blutbild.
Und ich würde natürlich eine Abdomen-Sonographie bei ihm veranlassen.
Gegebenfalls im Verlauf eine Koloskopie kommt ihm Frage.
Wenn mein Verdacht sich erhärtet,
würde ich den Patienten Stationen aufnehmen
und großlümige Zugang legen.
Danach Flüssigkeit geben
und je nach Beschwerden Antispasmalitikum
oder Antiemetikum, Analgetikum.
Hat er Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Haben Sie gefragt?
Wasserlassen habe ich nicht dauerweit erzählt.
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Es ist eine wichtige Frage, die sich stellen müssen.
Ja, wer beschwert ihn beim Wasserlassen hat,
der kann ja beides haben.
Schmerz, Munterbau, aber auch Beschwerden beim Wasserlassen.
Haben Sie ihn gefragt,
ob der ist schon 50 Jahre alt.
Haben Sie gefragt, ob er schon mal eine Darmspielung gehabt hat?
Eine Koloskopie bekommt man schon mal?
Nein.
Das ist eine wichtige Frage, die man stellen muss.
Das ist keine Operation.
Da ist keine Operation.
Da spielen wir seine Ineskopische Untersuchungen, die man ambulant macht.
Da muss man den Patienten noch nicht aufschneiden.
Ja, sollte man auch fragen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie den Verdacht einer Gastroenteritis haben.
Das muss anders sein.
Außer Gastroenteritis.
Das wäre möglich, aber für das Alter ein bisschen untypisch.
Aber es könnte sein, tatsächlich haben Sie recht.
Was könnte es noch sein?
Er hat die Bauchschmerzen im linken Unterbau.
Eine Appendizistin.
Könnte auch sein, richtig.
Aber es könnte viel wahrscheinlicher sein, als ein Andererkanten.
Eine Reisdarm-Sendronen.
Eine Sigma, die vertikulitis.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist höher, dass er eine Sigma, die vertikulitis hat.
Die Symptome passen er dazu.
Aber es könnte nicht sein, dass er eine Sigma hat.
Das ist eine Sigma, die vertikulitis hat.
Die Symptome passen er dazu.
Aber es könnte eine ganz normale Gastroenteritis sein.
Sie haben recht.
Bei einer normalen Gastroenteritis,
würden die Patienten meist nur Durchfall haben.
Und nicht Stuhlenwechsel haben.
Die hätten noch viel, die wären viel öfter auf Toilette.
Wir erwarten vielleicht auch bei Patienten
mit vertikulitis.
Was ist das für ein vertikulitis?
Ist es ein vertikulitis?
Nein, das muss nicht unbedingt sein.
Was die Patienten öfters haben, ist z.B. Fieber.
Aber dieser Patient hatte keinen Fieber.
Bei der Sigma, die vertikulitis,
muss man keinen Blut im Stuhl haben.
Sehr oft, dass sie keinen Blut im Stuhl haben.
Was sie aber oft haben, ist parallel.
Parallel kann sein.
Was die Patienten beschreiben,
ist nach dem Stuhlgang oder nach dem Luftablassen,
dass es ihnen besser geht.
Ja, eine besser auch.
Das ist typisch.
Und vertikulitis Patienten.
Oder es kann eine vertikulose
ohne Entschlünung bleiben.
Dann haben die keine Schmerzen.
Eine vertikulose macht keine Schmerzen normalerweise.
Eine vertikulose hat erst alle Schmerzen,
wenn sie entzündet sind.
Was wäre, kommt zum Einsatz in Diagnostik?
Diagnostik haben sich schon richtig gesagt.
Die untersuchenden Patienten,
typisch ist ein Druckschmerz im Denkenunterbau.
Wenn sie den Patienten untersuchen,
kann aber auch mittig sein.
Wenn der Sigma mittig abgeht,
kann auch sein, dass er hinter der Blase ist.
Was die Patienten,
die sie auch machen müssen,
ist ein Ultraschall.
Wenn der Patient gut zu schallen ist,
wenn sie den Untersuchungen gut machen können,
können sie eine Diavetikulitis auch sehen.
Was kann man da sehen?
Die Flüssigkeit spiegelt,
wenn es ein Eleus vorliegt.
Zum Beispiel,
dann wäre das schon ein akuter Bau,
ein akutes Abdomenpass.
Aber bei einer Diavetikulitis können sie oft,
wenn es ausgeprägt ist,
sehen, dass es zu einer Darmbandverdigung kommt.
Das müssen sich im Internet anschauen,
die Bilder.
Das ist dann auch eine dicke Darmband.
Man sieht das so länger aus,
wie eine Wurst.
Manchmal kann man sogar auch den Darmbast
passen.
Dann ist das so dick.
Wie eine Wurst, wie so eine Weiz.
Das tut denen richtig weh.
Wenn der Darmband geschwollen ist.
Kann der Pfands sagen?
Mit was?
Der Pfands abdominiert.
Ab der Spannung.
Oder losз was es schmerzt.
Die haben eher einen Druckschmerz.
Keinen Loserschmerz.
Ich hatte vor einigen Tagen ein Patient.
Er hatte auch auf der rechten Seite
richtige Habtäerschpannung.
Er hatte Druckschmerz.
Er hatte auch Diavetikulitis.
Eine Ausgepräte.
Die man im Ultraschall sehr gut sehen konnte.
Es muss nicht immer links sein.
Es ist üblich.
Es ist ein drutschmerziger.
Es kann auch den gesamten Unterbauch betreffen.
Es kann eine apostatitis sein.
Ein Patient kann auch eine...
Ein apostatitis kann es sein.
Es kann auch eine chronisch-hanzündliche
Darmalkapnis sein.
Es kann viele Sachen sein.
Es kann auch eine apostatitis sein.
Was wichtig ist, ist die Blutabnahme.
Dort werden Sie sehen, ob der Entschündungszeichen hat oder nicht.
Oft ist das der Fall.
Was machen Sie dann therapeutisch bei den Patienten?
Welche Verdacht gehen wir aus?
Wir gehen hier aus von einer Diavetikulitis.
Diavetikulitis.
Wir können Antibiotika Therapie anfangen,
wenn das Entschündungszeichen vorliegt.
Genau, richtig.
Breitband Spektrum Antibiotika.
Dritte Generation Zephalosporin
oder Loro Chinolon,
wie Ziprofluxasin
und auch Metronyta Zoll.
Metronyta Zoll?
Das ist wirksam gegen anerbobere Bakterien.
Richtig, genau.
Also daneben
Elektrolytsubstitutionen,
wenn die Patient zu viel verliert.
Wenn Sie das alles richtig kreieren,
genau, und auch Schmerzmedikamente,
was würden Sie für Schmerzmedikamente geben?
Sie müssen die Ibuprofizie
das Richtige?
Ich würde Metronyta Zoll IV geben.
Genau, das hört sich gut an.
Das kann man machen.
Kann man bei diesem Patientin
jetzt eine Darmspiegelung machen?
Würden Sie das machen?
Weil er keine Warnsignale hat.
Für diese
Momentan, ich würde nicht empfehlen.
Aber ich würde auch die
Nachkontrolle empfehlen, im Verlauf,
weil Alta des Patienten
als Vorzuge untersucht und eine
Koloskopie empfehlen.
Ja, es gibt hier also,
wenn der Patient eine akute Infektion hat
mit erhöhten Infektzeichen und es geht nicht mehr um
die Vertikulitätsausgaben, die Sie im Ultraschall gesehen haben.
Sie können aber auch ein CT machen,
eine Computersomographie, das habe ich vergessen zu sagen.
Da kann man auch mit Kontrastmitteln ausmaß
diese Entzündung beurteilen.
Es gibt verschiedene Stadien, der
die Vertikulitäts-1A, 1B, 2SG,
und so weiter.
Man darf eigentlich in einer akuten Entzündung
keine Koloskopie machen.
Man sollte empfehlen,
dass man wie... Genau, warum?
Warum darf man das nicht?
Warum es kann zu einer
Perforation führen. Richtig, ganz genau.
Es ist zu gefährlich.
Der Dame ist entzündet, der Dame ist sensibel, vulnerable.
So kann man letztendlich auch eine
Dame perforation riskieren. Richtig.
Ein solcher Peritonitis.
Ja, ja, vollkommen richtig.
Es kann sogar sein, dass der Patient
jetzt unabhängig nochmal davon,
als um Diomatik, wenn er schon länger
bestehende Vertikulitis hat,
eine Akkusatum bekommen. Es gibt auch
perforierte Vertikuliten.
Zum Beispiel, eine gedäkt perforierte
Vertikulitis, die Dame ist perforiert,
aber es ist noch gedäkt.
Das ist im Prinzip zu keiner
ausgiebenden Infektion gekommen.
Bei so etwas muss man auch überlegen,
um bei den Patienten in Verlauf operiert zu können.
Eine dringend Operation wäre...
Genau.
Aber Sie machen nichts falsch,
wenn Sie den Patienten eigentlich sofort
ein Antibiotikum geben, damit haben Sie
das meiste, was Sie machen können, gemacht.
Sehr gut. Gibt es uns Fragen?
Oder haben wir etwas vergessen?
Nicht vergessen, aber ich habe eine Notiz.
Erhöhte Handsohle,
die im Blut hat der Patient gesagt.
Richtig.
Und der Kollegen hat gesagt,
dass die Arthritisurika eine Diagnose
gestartet hat.
Ich denke, das ist falsch.
Hat eine Hyperurikäme?
Hyperurikäme ist normal, aber...
Arthritisurika...
Nein, das ist nicht richtig.
Richtig, das ist falsch.
Noch etwas?
Vielleicht können wir darüber auch sprechen.
Die Klassifikation.
Die Klassifikation können Sie,
wenn ich eine Gewettekrise nochmal nachlesen.
Die geht von 1a bis, ich glaube,
lassen Sie mich nicht lügen bis 2b.
Ich bin mir auch nicht sicher, ob wir uns nachschauen.
Aber die kann man jetzt...
Aber die können Sie jetzt in der Abgutphase
nicht verifizieren.
Sie müssen dafür einen CT machen meistens,
um das zu sehen, um den Ausmaß zu sehen.
Das geht... ich gucke mal kurz nach.
Es geht tatsächlich von 1 bis...
Typ 4.
Also, da gibt es verschiedene Klassifikationen.
Also, ich habe eine Klassifikation, die ich hier bin.
Sie sind zum Beispiel Hansen Klassifikationen,
aber ich habe so genannt.
Hinshake Klassifikationen, das ist ein bisschen unterschiedlich.
Ja, okay.
Also...
Wir benutzen hier meistens, also in meiner Klinik war das so,
in meinen CT, wo ich gar Arbeit gehabt habe,
dass wir die Typ 1 bis also 4 habe ich
mit der Diabetes-Gelutung und auch Kaforation.
Aber ansonsten...
eine andere Einteilung habe ich jetzt nicht im Kopf.